next question hey David does political
centrism make any sense or is it a
cop-out uh I don't believe centrism is a
cop-out but let's think about it this
way you're basically saying with
centrism here's the Overton Window of
what's valid debate pick any issue this
is the sort of left bound of the debate
this is the right wing bound of the
debate centrism is picking a spot in the
middle now centrism often I hear the
question phrased as a centrism
principled or is it just political
posturing if you believe something if
your political beliefs genuinely are
those that make you a centrist then it's
certainly genuine I don't know how you
can argue that it's not genuine but we
have to distinguish sort of between two
types of centrists okay you can be a
centrist on individual issues or you can
be a centrist in terms of where you are
on the political spectrum I'll give you
examples of both so you understand the
difference if you're a centrist on
individual issues that means for example
if we pick abortion for example you take
what you consider to be a sort of a p'
middle-of-the-road position between the
two extremes on that issue you might
take the position out I don't even know
what a centrist abortion position would
be it should be legal but only for
medical emergencies or during the first
I don't know ten weeks or something like
that and I know I'm dipped like stepping
into dangerous territory because people
will either say David that's not a
centrist position that's a very left
position or a very right position
depending on your politics but that
could mean like you're in the middle on
abortion or on gay marriage you want gay
marriage legal but firing people for
being gay also to be legal I mean I
think that's a crazy position I'm making
it up but the idea is on individual
issues you're in the middle then there's
a different type of centrism which is
that you're a centrist on the totality
of issues in other words you have some
left-wing arguments on some issues but
you have some right-wing arguments or
positions like you're on the left on gun
control but you're on the right on taxes
or whatever these are two
things but in either case I actually
find the analysis of centrism to be
pretty similar is centrism going to
achieve significant change in society no
no I mean to some degree when you say
you are a centrist you are saying some
combination of things are sort of ok the
way they are in the sense that today the
status quo is somewhere in the middle of
where the left and the right want us to
be that could be one interpretation or
you were saying that my positions are so
much the average of everything that's
out there that if my agenda were enacted
there would be no significant change to
speak of and I think both are kind of
losing positions in terms of making
positive change in society centrism as
an ideology can be a cop-out or it can
be that you genuinely sort of think
things are ok the way they are or it can
be that on some issues you're on the
left and on some issues you're on the
right but you're not interested in in
systemic change either way to me it's
not very interesting rarely is the
middle the right place in the political
world in reality although very few
issues are actually black and white in a
sort of zero or one binary kind of way
rarely is just picking the middle the
right spot on abortion the middle is not
the right spot on economic justice the
middle is not the right spot and a lot
of the divides that we experience today
and this is I think the most important
thing a lot of the divides that we have
today are some people call it tribalism
Jonathan Hite calls it Group --is--
nests whatever term you want to apply to
it you can't really negotiate on a lot
of these things these are reactions
these are positions people have not
because they because they've sort of
reasoned their way into them but because
they are gut fundamental feelings that
they have on a number of different
issues and you're not going to be able
to sort of talk out a compromise with a
lot of people on a lot of these
important
issues so what exactly does being a
centrist get you in that context I don't
think very much there are issues where
centrism and compromise is possible
immigration would be an idea on
immigration you actually might be able
to get some kind of centrist compromise
and maybe it would be reasonable to do
that
overall I see it as an unpretentious and
objective breaking news just being in
the middle on an issue doesn't make you
any less biased or more objective than
having a more politically polarized
position it could be the right position
it could be the wrong position you could
have it for genuine reasons or
disingenuous reasons but there's nothing
uniquely interesting about just being in
the middle so for me it's not super
interesting and I don't pay too much
attention to it